[Music]
you know what little rib has
um so let's get deep with it
yeah patreon's here it's queer get used
to it
it's not going anywhere it's really not
going anywhere guys so
so just jump like jump on board either
with us
or against us you're either a petrophobe
and a bigot and you need to die or
you're part a fan
so it's up to you it's your choice it's
your choice the choices are actually
simple
yeah it's open and shut case it is so
yeah man join the party that's going on
over there uh we're having a good time
and uh as always guys i hope you're
having a fantastic monday
um or sunday if you're on patreon can
you get it early so whatever
um sheamus plug and um obviously jump on
the merch guys
you got the shits and gigs you got the
thick you've got the danga dangs you got
the
whatever you call it all the good stuff
and um
as usual show us some love in the likes
the comments
and uh yeah man we move we do move guys
well you got g
um you might already know this one
because it's a basketball related fun
fact
um so shaquille o'neal made only one
three-point shot he had
shaquille o'neal made the only
three-point shot he would ever make in
his entire career
on february 16th 1996. when the orlando
magic played the milwaukee milwaukee
bucks
o'neil received an almost full court
pass before he shot a three-pointer
despite being the only official
three-point shot in his career he went
down
in history as one of the greatest of all
time gang i did i had no idea about that
i haven't seen that many like golden era
games
like shaq and kobe i've seen more kobe
games
um after shaq had retired i'm not saying
you would have seen it but i thought you
may have like heard it yeah
yeah yeah i i actually haven't i
actually haven't the same as
there's a lot of like um
like shaq stuff uh like vince carter
stuff
tracy mcgrady stuff that like i just
have never
dug deep into yeah allen iverson stuff
that like you know about a couple of
them yeah but it just like i don't know
you
i just know them more for their like
face and name than a more know about
like
um like famous plays and stuff that they
did okay fair enough yeah i don't know
that much about their their
their that actual career and like the
cool [ __ ] that they did
all i know is just like the famous
crossover from
alan on jordan and um
like um what else
i didn't even know that one about shaq
um kobe i know a lot about
but yeah apart from that they're from
them times i don't really know that much
about it
and i really should man because those
are that's the those are the good old
days
those were the good old days speaking of
ball steph curry's on stuff
at the minute have you seen him i've not
seen because i watched
more time obviously because we're in the
uk uh some games are like 2 a.m 3 a.m so
i kind of watched the replays
but i think who did they play recently
they
they played um was where's the team that
um
don check is don chitcha's on what's his
name what team is he in again
uh i saw that one
um god what's going on my head
doesn't matter yeah i saw that game yeah
um but i've not seen the game that i
played i think yesterday or two days ago
so i need to
oh okay cool um yeah he's been on stuff
he's been on nasty stuff
so like even his like his his drives to
the basket yeah
some of the just i have to be first i
saw one drive where he like eurostepped
and then went under the basket
yeah bro yeah he did one in uh he did
one in practice the other day
where he did like the eurostip windmill
but then instead of doing reverse he
just dipped it straight up
so say say like the the hoops right in
front of your face here yeah
typically you'd have to reverse it man
just shut it up like that and just
it didn't make sense fam it didn't make
sense
what my man can do just doesn't it just
doesn't add up it doesn't add up he's
who's his role model again
his name he faces in my head i can't
remember his name um
the guy he always tries to emulate
especially when especially when he makes
a good bucket
he does like all these like shoulder
stuff and blah blah blah he's like
hand stuff he got it from someone else
obviously that's in the past but i can't
for life me i can't remember he's like i
can't remember i can't remember
um yeah i'm not doing well as a
basketball fan today i'm not doing well
at all
um but um
i have for you would you rather i'll go
straight into it would you rather
yes so this is interesting one
would you rather see into the future
but can't say to anyone what you saw or
read minds
but you have to disclose what you know
to that person straight away
see into the future but not be able to
say what i've seen
mm-hmm or read minds and have to
immediately disclose what i've read
or what i've yeah yeah yeah quickly read
damn so i'm basically telling them what
they thought
if i'm reading mines so yeah let's just
say you just like
you're just in a bar you bump into a
thing you read her mind
uh and she's down and she's trying to
play koi and you're just like
you have to say like i do know you're
down by the way
damn i do know you're down i know you're
trying to play koi but i do know that
you're actually down damn
that's that [ __ ] blocks the whole thing
because
i've always wanted we've spoken about
this before i think i've always wanted
the ability to read minds but selective
minds
yeah yeah but having to say have to
having to say on the spot
actually um i'd probably because of
because of the fact that i wouldn't want
to just say
anything and any to anyone i'd probably
go for
the future one yeah yeah
because i would probably be able to put
myself in the right place at the right
time for certain events yeah
i said i can't tell people [ __ ] yeah
everything which should potentially work
to my advantage oh 100 i mean
i've always been like um i've always
just had like
those weird daydreams where you you go
into the past
and then you find out oh there's this
guy called jeff who's starting this like
stupid little
like business called amazon okay and
i've got like
20 pounds on my name because i'm like
four years old yeah and i'm like
put that on amazon put that on amazon um
so yeah i've always sort of cool stuff
like that and like i just used to
imagine
i i'm trash at music anyway but i always
just imagine like what if you could
you could you could meet the person
before they've made the song
okay and then you just like you i don't
know you meet like
15 year old chris brown and you're like
bro how about this like
you you imagine this video bro you're
chasing down this girl and
you're doing all of this and then you
just like you get a ball and you just
pull it up and it's like
i don't know you could call it like i
don't know excuse me miss just excuse me
yeah yeah yeah yeah excuse me miss and
she's and he's like yeah
yeah i like the song excuse me miss he's
like tell me more about this
talk to me more about this one's like
you know you just you talk about dancing
just like um i know you're trying to
leave but excuse me miss
yeah i say it's the last dance for you i
was like oh
that sounds like number one
yeah i think you do you're right you can
have it for a mil
you can have it for a million i wasn't
expecting you to say that
i must said it with chest now whole tone
yeah yeah yeah but you can have it for a
mil you can have it for a meal
me to pee now i have to wet my beak and
all my transactions dude
i'm not just giving out songs for free
[Laughter]
run me a mill that's hilarious but yeah
i always have little things like that so
i'd love to see into the future
i'd love to see in the future i've
always like fantasized about going back
in time and doing my life over again but
being able to just
make different decisions so you'd have
would you have the same knowledge yeah
so i'd go back and i'd have all the same
knowledge yeah but somehow i would have
to finesse it so perfectly
that i'm not just like god i want to
kill myself and also
you you know the knowledge but it would
have to feel like a memory
because you couldn't feel like a 30 year
old man in a 10 year old's body
because now i don't fancy anyone yeah
you know what i mean
i'd have to go back it had to be like a
memory yeah because i couldn't go back
to all of like my previous questions i'm
like right i've got a pattern this
question is because then i go back and
i'm just looking at like a 14 year old
girl like yeah yeah this is disgusting
do you know what i mean so you'd have to
go back i'd have all the memories but
they'd feel like memories
so they'd be like a little bit hazy but
enough for me to just like
i know if i do this instead of this this
is gonna work out better and i just know
that
rather than like i remember this day
when i lived it before i want to do this
i'd have i would want it to feel like a
little bit of a memory but just like
a clear enough memory so i'm like now
let's do this instead of this this
reminded me i don't know if it was a
tick-tock
i saw i saw a video on twitter but i
can't remember it was about
uh deja vu so um there was a theory
going
speaking of theories that we talked
about there was a theory going around
about like
reincarnation about when you die you're
born again or someone else etc
so they were saying oh when you die you
know when people say that oh
they see this this light at the end of
the tunnel kind of thing when they're
dying
so they're saying that when you die that
this light that you're seeing
is obviously you're coming out as a
newborn baby kind of thing so when you
come out now you're crying because
you're you're kind of upset at how you
died or like
what the life you were living before
kind of thing and then the more
you grow up the more you forget about
the old life you've had
because you're crying because you've
just died so you've remembered it so yes
you're crying because you've just died
and you've remembered everything and how
you've died in blah blah so you're angry
at the world as soon as you come out
so the more and more you grow up the
more and more you forget about your
previous life
but then you have snippets of deja vu
and thinking big man i've done this
before
i've [ __ ] done this before and it
makes you think like oh
that's that's interesting that's an
interesting theory it's very
out there very very out there yeah i saw
it and i was thinking okay
i've probably butchered a story but that
was the context yeah that's cool
i like that idea though i was like wow
okay deja vu stresses me out
stresses me out you know what stresses
me out because i can always
remember uh it makes me believe that
it's not real but it is real
because i can always remember the next
bit but it's always as it's happening
do you know what i mean i happen to be
all the time not all the time but every
time i have deja vu i'm thinking
i know what's going to happen next and i
think i'm losing my mind yeah i know
what's going to happen next but as
i i'm knowing what happens next is
actually happening
and i'm always like i knew that was
going to happen yeah but it's like
there's no way yeah because it's just
you yeah just you and your viewers yeah
and it's just like a reminder it's not
like
this is going to happen next where i can
be like oh this is going to happen
it's always like yeah that was that was
always
my head's always like yeah that that is
what was going to happen next so you see
this stuff have you feel oh yeah of
course
yeah yeah see this happening i think
deja vu and and then it moves on to the
next one and i'm like
it's almost like i can remember it but i
have to see it you know what i mean you
know when i'm like trying to
find a describe a film to you or
whatever and you're like oh it's
it's like first builder's day out yeah
and you're like
yeah it is first peter's day out yeah
that's exactly what it was you know what
i mean this is like
it's never enough for me to be like it's
this and then everyone be like
you just told the future i mean what do
you mean
it's never that so it makes it always
makes me believe like maybe it doesn't
exist then
maybe deserve it isn't real because it's
never it's not i'm never ahead of time
it's always
i'm remembering it as it's happening
that's happening it's that's a weird
concept
wow but yeah it's super weird that's
trippy hell
jesus christ um right
seeing as we've got so deep into like um
mindset and stuff like that yeah in the
last episode i was thinking
if you had to go see a therapist
and they were asking you all typical
therapist questions okay
what do you think they would
figure out about you not figure out but
what
do you think they would give like a
diagnosis to
to you to like as a on a negative aspect
like you know when people say oh like i
um
i don't even know like i am uh
co-dependent because
um x y and z or like similar to love
when we talk about love languages like
oh
i'm like i like acts of service because
of because of this is this do you think
there's anything you're like
i am this way and i know i'm this way
and i think if i saw a therapist they
would say
you're this way do you think there's
anything like in your personality that's
like that
probably yes um should be fair more than
probably yes
um but i feel like i feel like that's
deep
i feel like that's deep for the pod it's
too deep it's too deep for them because
i feel like
obviously you said i'm this way because
of my parents and blah blah i feel like
i'll be exposing them as well
all right you didn't have to say that's
fine it's not sign i want to say on it
that's cool i mean you don't have to say
why though you can just say i think
they'll say
that i'm this i think they'll probably
say because obviously i told you um
one of my biggest fears is um or my
probably biggest fear is that not being
able to drive with my kids
and that's i feel like that's obviously
stemmed from my childhood oh sorry i
mean yeah yeah
that's something that's obviously prior
to this podcast
that's something i don't really tell
people do you know what i mean yeah
this is a different platform and it's
just is what is kind of thick and
it's something that has always stuck
with me and it's always one of those
ones where
you just say it to yourself not
necessarily over and over and over again
but it's it's always there
yeah it's always in your subconscious
just thinking that i can never let
not necessarily not not that not
necessarily not what happened to me
happen
again but like i'm just going to put
myself in positions where
it's just never going to be an option
for me to even be in that position yeah
yeah
i need something i'm going to resolve it
before it's even an issue yeah exactly
so i don't have kids now but i know for
a fact that
i'm trying to be comfortable before i
have kids yeah yeah yeah yeah
that makes sense so that is something
not necessary
that i struggle with but it's more of a
case of i am
struggling with something that i
probably shouldn't even i'm struggling
with something that isn't
a struggle right now because i'm trying
to prevent the struggle
so that is that's the one of the first
if i open my true heart to the therapist
the 100 told me that
100 do you think that would give you any
option
of changing that mindset
without that so for example like in your
head
you having money by the time you've had
kids is the only resolution to that
that mindset that you've got now that's
the only way you can solve it
is the resolve do you think there's
anything they could say we're like
well have you ever thought about it this
way and maybe you wouldn't feel that way
um i've actually not thought about it
because
i've not it's not something i've voiced
you know i mean i don't have
i would never have another opinion about
it so if they did and it was probably a
viable option i'd probably be in denial
at first and be like nah that's
never going to satisfy my needs yeah
yeah i need to be rich and that's the
only thing that's the only answer
and it's not necessarily rich i don't
want to sound like stuck up and say rich
it's just i want to be very very
comfortable
yeah yeah yeah so it's one of those ones
where i probably
wouldn't want to take their advice or
believe it will be
the right move for me to take like like
you said we performed a few episodes
where like a [ __ ] road kind of thing
i'm always probably going to go for my
option a
than their option b and it's just
probably because
because i know my life and obviously i'm
the only one that's lived my life i can
only see this
option as being the viable option but
yes they're the professionals
so for them to be giving me another
option i'll probably be
very stubborn about trying to even
decide to go for an eruption yeah yeah
so it'll be one of those it'll be hard
for me yeah it's tough as well because
obviously your thing
isn't like at it it's not a detriment to
anyone
yeah so it's only a good thing you know
i mean yeah it's like when people
um are like addicted to fitness yeah
they use the fact that it's healthy as a
justification obviously
it's okay it doesn't matter because it's
a healthy thing to do like i remember
when i was
like addicted to the gym and stuff like
that and so now that the gyms are
[ __ ] close that i'm actually
realizing like
i think a few years ago i had an issue
like i would lose it if i couldn't go to
the gym for one day
like if i had to if i had to choose
something
um if i had to cancel jim for someone
else if my mom or if my like partner or
anyone needed me to do something
that meant i had to cancel the gym i
would resent the [ __ ]
out of them so it would piss me off
now the gyms are closed i'll probably be
more likely when they open i'd be like
it's whatever because different
perspectives yeah it's different
perspective now but yeah i think if i
went to
they would have a field day with me if i
had to go see a therapist they would
think
big man i know i'm i'm i'm gonna retire
with this guy yeah this guy's going to
put me
put my kids through college because he's
got issues i'm going to keep coming back
we've got so much to unpack he's going
to be here for a minute
so let's just get comfy um now i don't
think i think there's there's a few
things in there
that like some of them i can trace back
as to like what the root causes of it
some of them i don't really know what
the root causes are
but just like for example um
i definitely have an issue with i
wouldn't necessarily call it
perfectionism because i understand that
everything is perfect but i
always have a you you would have noticed
it more probably since we started the
pod
i am obsessed with making things better
yeah like when i said good enough it's
not good enough good enough isn't good
enough
yeah good enough isn't good enough that
is a fault i have of myself
in terms of like everything that i
intend if i i'm very much like i don't
give a [ __ ] about anything
but if i i'm open enough to say that
this is something that i do give a [ __ ]
about
then good enough isn't good enough yeah
and i won't stop until i'm literally the
best person at this yeah and i think
that stems from
my dad okay in that i've said it before
you can't impress him yes yes you told
me it's [ __ ] impossible yeah
no no matter what you can't impress him
and um
there's uh i don't know if i've told you
about this before there's
a uh like i i want to impress him so bad
that
it makes me want to punch him in the
face you know what i mean yeah
it's not even like uh it's at this stage
i'm so desperate to impress my dad
this is so pathetic i'm so desperate to
impress my dad that when i finally do
impress him and he has to admit that
he's impressed
it's more of like not even going to be
like a sentimental like
oh god i finally got the like
appreciation from my dad that i've
always wanted it's going to be like
[ __ ] you bruv yeah yes i finally did it
you're impressed you lose bruh and i win
i know exactly what you sure i mean yeah
it's
like yes i [ __ ] did it yeah like i'm
the best guy of all time
like i impressed my dad yeah um it
reminds me there's a film called uh
ah what's it called describe it it's
called
um hot rod have you seen it no
it's the guy from you know the guy from
um what's that cop show called the jokey
cop show
tv show tv show it's on netflix now as
well
cop show it's the guy from um
um lonely island the band you know the
dick
oh i don't know g
i don't know the loneliness but i don't
know what show you're talking about he's
in um
i'm sure you've seen this show my
brother watches it all the time
someone's gonna be screaming like
[ __ ] this uh cop comedy
show on netflix it's
it's this show this show here oh
brooklyn nine-nine brooklyn nine-nine
fun yes i knew you knew what it was yeah
i've seen all of it
exactly brooklyn nine-nine yeah yeah so
hot rod
is from my man from brooklyn nine-nine
okay he is uh
a stunt uh would you stuntman okay
there's a
a [ __ ] one he's got like a little moped
that he tries to do little stunts on
yeah yeah and basically his stepdad
doesn't rate him as a man okay and he
needs he always fights his stepdad and
his stepdad always beats the [ __ ] out of
him and he's always like one day
i'm gonna [ __ ] like knock you out
yeah and you're gonna respect me
and he said i always say you unless you
beat me in combat like
you're not a man and you'll never have
my respect so his
life goal is to [ __ ] beat up his
stepdad and his stepdad uh has heart
failure
and he needs a heart transplant and um
he's basically saying like
i'm gonna die and you'll never get my
respect
oh wow so he he the whole film is him
about
trying to pattern the best stunt to
raise enough money
to get his step-dad's heart transplant
just so he can get the harsh parts
around just so i can [ __ ] him up
and finally get a step dad's respect
it's a jokes film that's how i feel
okay okay okay i'm so desperate to
impress my dad yeah and to succeed and
to be
like wealthy and well off and stuff like
that so i can buy him the car buy him a
car that he could never afford yeah
that's what i'm desperate to do
get him the aftermath that he could
never afford even though he can't afford
an estimating
but like it just needs to be cited that
he can't handle yeah you know what i
mean
something he could never patent yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then just like
i even i think i writ in his last
birthday or christmas card i think i
wrote like
thank you for teaching us that unless we
make more money than you then we're not
[ __ ]
and that is like my sole motivation in
my life he probably read that and
sniggered he did he read it in front of
me and he laughed oh isaac yeah and he
was like as long as you know
your dad's ruthless i love it i love it
i love it
as long as you know that's jokes bro he
doesn't play that's jokes
uh i think she i think it's for his
birthday last year um so yeah i think if
i saw a therapist they'd be like we need
to deal with this
we need to because yeah you're setting
like unattainable expectations of
yourself
but same as you when you said like with
this with the thing is like
but the result is a positive one yeah
like in terms of what i the the
the pressure i put on myself to get to
that point
will give me good things out of life so
achieving that goal
once i've achieved it my life will be
good yeah
but it's just like psychologically it's
it's not healthy
it's not healthy like i'm saying like i
like to improve the quality of this
pod like the hours and stuff i'm going
through yeah to just to just do
better things yeah and it happened like
it used to happen with basketball you'd
have more boxing and stuff like that i
used to put myself through
torment because if i saw that doing this
thing is a route
to something that i might impress my dad
yeah eventually down the road i'm like
i'll give my soul for this damn bro it's
nuts
it's nuts that's unhealthy for one uh
and i think like another one
is i don't know what the root of this is
but it's like i hate owen
no i hate owen people [ __ ] yeah for one
i know that i [ __ ] hate it and i hate
asking people for things
for favors i can't stand it i know i
can't
stand it i don't know why i don't know
what the root of that is i can't say the
thought of someone having something over
me
even if they're like a friend of mine
and it's not even over me do you know
what i mean
like when jay offered to let me crash
when i'm up in manning to crash at his
places and stuff that i didn't want any
money for it
like mine i've i've come to accept it
now and i'm more comfortable with it now
yeah but
man's time first time yeah i have to
give you something
i don't want anything like shut up and
i'm just saying like
vex thinking [ __ ] this like now i owe
this guy something
like [ __ ] and it took a lot for me to
just like breathe i'm like cool he's my
boy it's fine
like so whatever i'll pay him back
someday yeah but even now it still
sticks in my head thinking
one of these days brother i'm just going
to book him a trip to dubai and i'm not
even going to tell him i'm just going to
buy it he's going to be first class
and he's going to have to do it and he's
going to not have a choice yeah
because if you offer him he'll say no so
i'm just in my head i'm always thinking
like little sneaky ways that i can pay
him back
like i need to it's it's stressful in my
head if soon as someone does something
for me
bro it's stressful and like yeah i think
i don't want to say because i feel like
i've always felt this way there's
obviously
times in my life where i'm thinking this
is probably why i feel this way like
there's times where like
my mom stresses about money stress is
about money so like she used to
i think her way of use of teaching us
the value of money
is that if you ever borrowed money off
her she's on your back
yeah so i remember where there was times
when i was younger i used to ask my mom
for like 10 pounds
and she better know when that when that
10 pounds coming back yeah
and it used to vex me because i used to
think you're my mom my boys get 10
pounds for
banter for free because no questions no
questions asked yeah
and then yeah you should be like big man
where's that 10 pound like why don't you
have that she wants a special why
haven't you got 10 pounds
why don't you have it where is it what's
going on
and it used to be like i don't want no
one to owe me nothing or times where
like for example
where there was a time where like
um i think i moved when i was
obviously i'd already felt this way but
this is like where i'd uh
moved out of home and moved back in with
my mum
and um yeah obviously yeah
got rid of the house and then moved back
in with my mum and it was just like that
whole like [ __ ] yeah
i owe her for this yeah because this is
nothing but an inconvenience for her to
benefit me that there's no there's no
two ways about this
and it was just like that was just like
it's like bro this is your house yeah
this is like your your mum hasn't mum
hasn't changed my room yeah that's from
when i
used to live here you grew up i grew up
here it's like chill but even that i was
just like
no you can't i can't i physically cannot
damn bro it used to stress
me out to no end
to no end bro and i end up doing [ __ ]
that's above and beyond
to try and even the playing field you
know what i mean
where it's just like oh cool like even
when i said to you in the car earlier
like oh i might need to take
um some money out of the account yeah
yeah yeah to pay for this thing yeah
even though that thing isn't even for me
i still have the mentality of like
well maybe if i do this then we can
level it out or maybe if i
i'll give you some i'll let you have all
the much money for next month like even
then i'm still having to talk myself
thinking like um damn bro
bro that's i don't know where the root
of that is but that is
like i think you've actually because
sorry it's got you off
um something with me is that i feel like
every human being needs therapy
regardless
it's so essential i think they do and i
feel like
therapy therapy would be great if it was
free obviously because i feel like
everyone needs it at some stage of their
life
they don't know even you could be the
happiest person today but
there are probably some things that
you've not spoken about in like the last
five
six seven years that because they're so
buried you've kind of
just you say you've gotten over it but a
trigger word might bring something back
out
and i'm not trying to live that life i'm
not trying to live a trigger life i'm
trying to live a trigger free life bro
i'm trying to be chill and i feel like
therapy for male and female i think
men especially men especially men don't
see therapists men
don't see therapists because what they
don't not that they don't see there
because i'm sure they do but i'm
assuming they don't see
them as much as women because men
always have to carry the burden um men
carry
so much burden i was talking to bella
the other day and though this is a few
weeks ago actually i said the other day
she was talking to me about some stuff
and i was saying to her like i said this
i think i've said it on podcast before
as well
just because i carry it well doesn't
mean ain't heavy yeah yeah you said
yeah um but we were talking about
specific things in my family and she was
talking about specific things in her
family and she was like oh wow i never
knew you kind of went through that and i
was like
of course like people every family has
their [ __ ] it's true
every family is true as much as as much
as what you think you're going through
is [ __ ]
right now trust me someone else has had
something either worse
or not even as worse but someone else is
going through stuff or has gone through
stuff
it doesn't have to be similar but it's
traumatic to them yeah
it's just stuff that you have to carry
throughout the rest of their life until
they get over that hurdle point
it was only last summer that me and my
dad actually i think i spoke about this
on here as well me and my dad actually
had a great conversation
it wasn't about anything specific it
wasn't like i'll sit down and i'll talk
to you about this
we just had a conversation it was me my
sister her husband my nephew and my dad
were at my dad's house
and we were just talking for hours we
were watching the football game we were
just talking for hours and hours and
hours
we were just laughing and joking talking
about when i was young when she was
young all the [ __ ] that happened blah
blah blah
and we were just laughing and it's
banging that sounds like therapy in
itself exactly it was therapy in itself
and it felt like a weight lifted off my
shoulder i felt like
he was my boy ah i would kill for that
it felt like he was my bone was such a
great feeling tyler i'd kill for
such a great feeling to have and it was
like
me and my dad have never had a couple it
was like i've held
unbeknownst held some form of grudge for
so long up until that conversation yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and after that conversation i felt like
wow
i told my on new year's eve new year's
day i don't know if i said this on here
um i called my mom she was the second
person i spoke to
bella called me first and i spoke to i
called my mom straight away
uh she's like happy new year blah blah
blah everything so she was talking to me
from my mom my mom
if every african parent knows that when
your mom calls you on like your birthday
or any like kind of holiday kind of
thing she's she's on the phone for five
minutes just praying for you
just praying in your if you're nigerian
she's praying for you in europe she's
just praying praying praying this study
and everything you're just like amen
amen amen every african knows this
now that sounds intense right i'm used
to it yeah yeah it's one of them
i was just like hey man i don't know
what i'd do someone said that to me now
your eyes will be damn bit but i'm used
to that so it's it's not
it's the normal thing yeah and for some
reason i just wanted to
express gratitude towards my mind i
always do anyway she like i told you
before
she messaged me almost every day just to
know if i'm a live candidate she just
says hi and i say hi
but i was like mom i want to tell you
something she was like what she was like
mum i want to let you know that i can
understand
that everything you've done for me and
my sister has been for the benefit of us
like
yeah what you've put what you've gone
through what you've what you thought you
put us through everything i just want
you to know that i love you so much
and everything you've done for us i
understand and the trials and
tribulations you went through we get you
i told you
she was working two jobs yeah yeah yeah
and the other and i just wanted to let
you know that
mom i understand like i'm at a point
where i've come to a situation
in my life where because i've found
purpose now
i understand things a lot clearer the
i can see light at the end of the tunnel
now yeah and that's oh that's due to
this podcast
yeah yeah due to this podcast because
now i know that this is happiness for me
there's nothing else holding me back
anymore yeah this is the main reason why
i want to wait to have kids and wait for
all of this because i want this to be my
success
before i even dive into anything else
yeah because i don't want again the fear
of not being able to yeah
yeah so i just expressed the gratitude
towards her and she said to me
10 people could have offered her a
million pounds on that spot and she said
she would have taken she would have said
no just to hear that again
wow that breaks my soul
i knew i've not cried in god knows how
long i nearly shed a thug dear
i was saying bro that would make me
cough
don't take the wind out of me man jesus
christ yeah
that's a lot it was good for me to say
because i i wanted her to know she knows
obviously these yeah
as a child you know your mum loves you
and vice versa yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but
i've never i know for a fact i've never
been that expressive to my mum in my
life
oh in my life yeah but probably when i
was a kid yes by the way yeah yeah but
like as a grown man
that i don't live there anymore utc i've
never been that way to her
and i just wanted her to know and it was
good it was a good way for me to start
my year
that sounds fantastic i mean i need to
do it it was fantastic bro
i'm probably not gonna do it i think you
will not
anytime soon there will be a time there
will be a time there will be a time when
it
feels appropriate yeah but i can't they
i'm too awkward i can't
decide like i can't we'll do that
tomorrow yeah i didn't i didn't plan on
you
have to be like on the spot it just
happened man we were talking talking
talking on the phone
i was like mum i want to tell you
something she was like what and i just i
just expressed myself
[ __ ] just expressing myself and i was
like whoo
that was good to say it's great to say i
bet you're the best sleep that night
it felt great to say i bet it was
amazing man so
that in itself was therapy for me and
like i said the conversation having my
dad last summer
it was just great to have it and again
that wasn't planned yeah yeah yeah
i think it's well especially when you
say like you have like these
subconscious grudges against people like
a lot of it it feels like you said just
feeling like your dad's your boy
a lot of it is actually like you said
you know what you said about um the
difference when you see like a
banging thing on instagram you need to
see them in person to realize that
they're human
yeah and they're not that banging
anymore they're not that intimidating
anymore they're just
a person a person like that's the same
with like parents you have a pet there's
a wall between
a person and a parent and when you're a
parent yeah you know that that like
you were their responsibility and any
wrongs that you met
were a failure as a parent you don't
necessarily see them as just a person
like you
you see them as a parent and if if if
you have these grudges it's their fault
because they're the parent and you're
the child
whereas all it would take is just like a
level to level conversation that you're
a man and he's a man
and you understand that like he said i
felt like he was my boy and all of that
will melt away
like you said it's like the instagram
y'all thought whatever
he's a person he's actually just a
person like he's just he struggles with
the day-to-day dramas that i struggle
with um and he was struggling with that
while he was dealing with my ass yeah
and he like made me realize it made me
realize that the stuff i thought i was
going through or just half of the things
that he was going through
yeah when you have kids like your
problems
what my problems are his problems as
well as his problems do you know what i
mean
yeah and it makes sense what you said
about the now you found purpose
because this pod for me
has been eye-opening in terms
of the things that you have to do to
chase
your dreams at the expense of
potentially other people
of course because i've always lived my
whole life in terms of like a hard shell
kind of
mentality of just like
just deal with it yeah do you know what
i mean so anytime people come to me with
not necessarily their problems i don't
have a issue people coming to me their
problems
it's just like either resolve it or
[ __ ] deal with it this is life and
life is hard and just deal with it
and that's always been my life while i'm
not well i haven't necessarily been
chasing anything yeah
i haven't necessarily been going after
anything i haven't been anywhere at the
thought i was chasing something but i
didn't have any direction yeah it was
just like my life was a process
of being hard and being a man and just
dealing with it
to get where you need to be in life like
you said like
if i had jobs where i have to wake up at
five o'clock in the morning and granted
like i have
the group chat have you and i would moan
but at the same time i would just deal
with it
but once we started this and you have a
vision and a path
and you can see the end goal it's not
necessarily okay it doesn't it changes
now it changes
and you you have to sacrifice [ __ ] in
your life
and you have to sacrifice other people
and you have to like what i said about
like every time i'm here like i'm
getting arguments with like chloe and
other people that
live in the city because i don't have
the time to see them and you said like
bro at the end of it like they'll
understand it
it's just like you have to you have to
not just put yourself first but you have
to try and
be a million different things yeah and
to a million different people whilst
trying to chase this one thing and it's
no longer a case of dealing with it you
have to be open with people and honest
with people and just being like i'm
sorry
and you deserve better and you deserve
better but you deserve better and
and i'm trying to do this thing and like
i have to i can't see you right now
because i have to dedicate
everything for this yeah and one day i
hope you'll understand
but right now it probably seems like i'm
just a prick yeah and it's the same with
the parents things it's like
they're probably thinking one day you'll
understand bro but this is a reason for
this
because we're chasing something greater
and you're gonna have a better life
afterwards
but right now you probably think i'm a
failure as a parent yeah and you're
going to grow up with
a grudge but like
you'll understand one day and that's the
same with this one
because we're chasing something now i'm
i'm constantly feeling like
guys you'll understand one day yeah it's
not just about me being egotistical and
people
like people would say to me now like oh
i haven't heard from you for like you're
too big for your boots now
a couple thousand followers you're too
big for your boots and i'm like i'm
literally not
yeah i promise you but i work like a
[ __ ] dog
yeah like i haven't had a lunch break
and god knows when yeah
like i work constantly and like again
like you said like the other week like
one day you will understand because one
day i'll have all the time in the world
one day i'll have all the time in the
world and then you'll be bored of me
ringing you
because i've got all this time but for
now you
i'm just gonna have to deal with the
fact that you think i'm a selfish prick
yeah you i'm gonna have to deal with the
fact that i think
that i'm i'm i'm too popular now for all
these low-level people i ain't got time
for friends no more
i'm gonna just have to deal with the
fact that you think that so that i can
chase this [ __ ] and make it up to you
later yeah and yeah you could i can see
that like
it would have to take to see someone on
that
same level to unders for them to
understand like
i don't have a grudge anymore because i
understand that this is hard this is
being an adult is hard
i feel like you get like you said um it
won't be now but like the conversation
when i have
your parents it will come yeah
100 like like obviously my dad still
grinds now but i still remember my dad
having luckily i didn't find it that
much of a pain at the time
but i easily could have like my dad used
to have to take us to work with him on a
saturday
i think you told me all the [ __ ] time
all the time
yeah and um we were just sitting in
office yeah with him
all day and just play on computers i'll
just play solitaire on like a computer
and his
empty office he'd be the only one in
this office there'd be like 200
computers in his office
and my dad would be the only one there
on a saturday when you're a kid you
don't think about it
you just if he wakes you up in the
morning like we're gonna have to go to
the office today some days i would have
been like oh for [ __ ] sake dad
it's saturday you're supposed to be here
chilling we're supposed to be swimming
and
theme parks and cool [ __ ] why are we
going to your office like you can't
physically comprehend that like
do you think my dad wants to go to
office on a saturday he's been here all
week
there's no one else here let you know
what i mean and now
like he's got a nice house and he's got
cars and he's got cash and
he can help me with [ __ ] all the time
whenever i need him and like that's
because
he spent times sacrificing weekends with
his kids
so he could go to work but it takes for
you to be here now
to understand those things and you don't
have a grudge anymore luckily i didn't
have a gadget but
it's it is lucky that i didn't have a
grudge against it
at my dad at the time because i was
computer mad
okay so he would just log me into a
computer put me on like mini clip
distracted
and just be like have fun fun and i'll
be on mini clip just playing all day and
i'm in my head i'm just like this is
sick yeah
and i don't even know so i got over the
garage and he'd always order us like
mcdonald's and stuff yeah we'd get
mcdonald's at lunch time so i'm like
bruh mcdonald's on computer all day like
it's not that bad
but it could have been an office that
was [ __ ] yeah he could have been a
solicitor
and i'm just sat there all day making
paper airplanes on but this is a
nightmare
do you know what i mean it could have
been a situation where it was [ __ ] and i
really really really resented him for it
but luckily it wasn't one of those
situations but even still now
it's taken me for me to have this
conversation with you thinking [ __ ]
maybe my dad didn't want to go to the
office on a saturday
maybe it wasn't his choice he had to go
in the office and work on the saturday
and bring his [ __ ] kids
of course he probably didn't want to do
that but
do you ever feel like um you're growing
up
to be your parents like you're acting
like your parents nowadays like your mum
or your dad like similar traits like do
you remember
do you remember specific examples of
stuff your dad used to do that you feel
like oh [ __ ] i do this now
yeah in terms of i think definitely in
terms of like uh
not expressing my issues
or struggles in my life to people that
um you know how i said we said on uh on
the other episode about
um if you knew when you were gonna die
i would tell you but i wouldn't tell
people who would
try and save me that'll be a day-to-day
influence kind of thing yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's how i am with everyday
struggles okay when i'm
really struggling with something like if
i'm broke and i'm down and out and like
i'm tired and like i don't know how i'm
gonna get through this day at work and i
don't know how i'm gonna
pay my bills this month and stuff like
that i will come to you
but i want to expect to my mom about it
like i won't speak to people
who care about me you know i may not say
you don't care about people but i won't
speak to people who
are correct yeah i wouldn't speak to
people who would worry about me because
i don't want to worry about that that's
my dad
i don't think i've ever heard an issue
at my dad's mouth and every time you say
ask my dad like you're right you'd be
like
yeah yeah yeah fine fine fine fine fine
just like trying to carry the birthday
judge trying to pay the bills in it
and then it just carries it it just
holds that that's one thing i'm
definitely like
i'd take from my dad and i try like i
don't get angry i think i take that from
my dad as well i don't get angry
i don't remember i rarely get angry i
get angry in a jokey way
yeah but i've never really like i never
like snapped yeah
like but that's my dad like i've seen my
dad snap like once
but then he snapped the voice goes up
and then immediately you can hear him
just like and he just
he just takes it i think i take that
from my dad fair enough
what about you um i def so when i was
younger
obviously my not obviously my dad's uh
football fanatic he loves he loves
chelsea
um and we always used to every time
chelsea was on usc it's the rave and
blah blah screaming
any football to be fair but obviously
you love chelsea um
but nowadays i've noticed myself because
i said to you oh i said to i said on the
pod
a few episodes ago remember which one is
um because of the times we're in now i
can watch football a lot more and i've
fallen in love with it again
i've noticed that i am my dad when i
watch football i swear yeah fam
anytime there's an and minor
inconvenience like oh he could have
passed it
i'm screaming at the tv james yeah i'm
screaming and this is my dad
to a team every time i do something it's
like [ __ ] i'm coming like my dad
[ __ ] i'm just like my dad yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah bro it's crazy that's exactly
funny you should say that i was saying
this
yesterday i was exactly like that with
cooking shows
my dad i used to come we'll come
downstairs on a saturday morning my dad
would be watching [ __ ] cooking shows
and i'm this is boring bruv
are you just gonna sit here and watch
cooking shows that's my i love watching
cooking shows now
my dad and documentaries back in the day
all i wanted was cartoon network
anything that was calm and childish
that's all i wanted to watch my dad will
watch documentaries fourth
time especially like national geographic
national geographic as well yeah
what are you watching you're you're such
a boring man yeah yeah yeah what we do
on this podcast is talk about
documentaries now
i love documentaries bro i'm becoming my
dad i am becoming my dad and i wonder if
my sister's becoming my mom
it's a question i've never asked her and
it's a question i've never asked my mom
has she seen like oh my sister's
becoming like her blah blah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
it's so weird man it's so weird as the
older you get
the more you realize you're just like
your parents you do become your parents
it's crazy you do become your parents
and you
it's weird because you become your
parents for just like the standard
day-to-day things
but you also become your the extreme
opposite of your parents in the things
that you didn't see
like the things that you don't like
about them yeah yeah and
there's no middle ground it's always
like whatever they did you're going to
do the opposite yeah
and then your kid is going to do the
opposite of the [ __ ] that they don't
like about you and it's just going to go
back and forth back and forth back and
forth back and forth
um yeah it's crazy so i'm exactly like
my pops in watching football but
i don't want to be like in that
situation where i was when i was kids so
that's what i'm always striving to
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly so it's
it's weird it's such a double edge
exactly and i
my parents worked all the time and i'm
trying to just
not i'm just trying to have as much free
time as possible yeah um
but whilst i'm working my ass off now
and i'm sure they were trying to do the
same thing
and i used to just think you might not
was working bro always working
always working from i'm working [ __ ]
67 hours a week now just to just
get to a point i don't have to work
anymore yeah and what i said i think i
said to you how this conversation
the one honest conversation i had with
my dad a few years ago just before we
started this
was um him talking about work
and it was the first time when i
actually said to him i want to try this
this pod thing on this youtube thing or
whatever and i was expecting him to be
like
yeah good luck i expect him to just
brush it off like childish things man
um but he was like ah do it do it
he said do it because i've been working
my whole life
so that i can retire at a certain age
and that age has been and gone oh wow
and i'm still working trying to retire
and you work and you work and you work
and you think when i make this much
money it'll be enough when i make this
much money or
i won't have to work hard anymore or if
i get this promotion i won't have to
work anymore and then you get to the
the top of the castle you get to the
peak of the mountain and you just find
out you're working more than you ever
were
yeah and that's him now he's like he has
to look after
everything you just got more people to
look up more responsibilities i've got
these employees i've got my kids
i've got this house i've got these cars
i've got
employees under the employees i've got
meetings upon meetings i've got clients
i've got this i've got everything is on
my shoulders
it's like i missed the days when i was
just the guy that had no responsibility
just at a desk
i was just like it didn't matter i could
not turn up for three days probably no
one [ __ ] even noticed
it's like you want so hard to get to the
top of the tower this is like corporate
world definitely is that you work so
hard to get the top and just to realize
the top is worse than the bottom
of course it is you just get paid more
that's it but you just it's worse than
the bottom
and like so when he said he's like do it
do this youtube thing please do it
because you don't he just basically said
don't be where i'm at yeah
because if youtube was about when i was
your age 100 i would have done it you've
gone clear yeah i know
box here would have been gone clear go
on you would be gone gone because i
remember the first time i told him he
was like bang
right this is what you want to do you
want this camera look this is what
camera that casey neistat uses you can
see the angle
this is this is this and this you want
to be doing this you want to be doing
this or you can look at this youtuber
look
look at the kind of stuff that they use
look at the color schemes that they're
using and like the similarities that
they have between the videos and the
differences but
they all connect together he was going
off on it brother okay so i've just
my mind is blown a little bit for now
because obviously we're talking about
how we um
how you're becoming your dad and
emulating your father and everything and
you're talking about like
how you don't have open conversations
blah blah blah yeah
and you're striving to impress your pups
yeah so do you feel like this is one of
the reasons why you do this as well
like subconsciously subconsciously
definitely i definitely think
i definitely think i try harder now from
that one conversation where i realized
like
this is something that he would have
wanted to do yeah and i might i have an
opportunity to potentially do it
that hundred percent like spurs me on
whenever i'm thinking oh bro that's gang
though man we're down [ __ ] 50
subscribers today bro we're not a new
subscriber in four days yeah like what's
the point
yeah when i'm thinking about that i
always think like i have an opportunity
to do something that
he always wanted to do yeah well not
necessarily because he didn't exist when
he was my age but like
in the realm that he wanted to in
hindsight he said if he knew the
opportunity if yeah if he was there for
him he would have done it and like
in an essence like i could be the guy
that's like
i don't have a job yeah my job is my
hobby
and i make more money than all of you
[ __ ] and
dad quit now because the house is what i
i just paid off the mortgage buff
that's what i want to do just like
the this is sorted it's sort of just
chill now just chill
this whole thing you've been banging on
about for a million years since i was a
[ __ ] kid
talking about oh no stop now
it's sorted it's patterned and also [ __ ]
you because it's the car you can't
afford you're impressed
my mom will break down into tears bro i
couldn't see it yes i'd want to see it i
couldn't see it yeah yeah yeah my
by my mom's house i've always i always
have these daydreams about like ring
them on because my mom rents her yard
and she it's such a stress in the back
of her head
that like i in my head is old school
mentality like i don't give a [ __ ]
i ever own in my yard but it's stressful
for her
and it stresses me out that it's stress
for her of course that every time her
like leases up for
renewal she is stressed fam
stressed thinking that the landlord is
just going to turn around and sell it
and kick her out she's so stressed about
it so i always have these dreams about
like just buying it not telling her
begging the landlord don't tell her
don't tell her don't tell her just leave
it and then we'll come round and it'll
be that same
i bought it [ __ ] six months ago and
she doesn't know and then she's just
been
paying like i would say just like i'm
this is such an inconvenience but like
i'll pay you extra
if like when my mom pays the rent just
forward it to me yeah when my mom pays
the rent just forward it to me
and like don't say anything just let it
let it go it's gonna be surprised and
when the [ __ ] lease
renewal comes around i want you to
[ __ ] ring her i'll pay
you like an extra 50 grand if you
pattern this for me yeah like when the
least renewal comes and just say like
ah i wanted him to like ring her and
just be like ah
right we need to have a conversation
about like the lace thing and stuff like
that and my mom's gonna be
having a [ __ ] heart attack yeah and
you're like right i'm really sorry but
i've sold the house
and she's gonna panic and she's like
dude i don't know what i'm gonna do
all right mom calm down i'm coming over
it's gonna be all right i'll be there in
a minute i'm coming over
and i've just got like the [ __ ] the
title deeds in my hand yeah
and i'm like bang there you go he did
that house to me to me
it's yours there you go she'd lose it
and here's the [ __ ]
eight grand that you've been paying for
the last six months
enjoy that damn that's that's great
that's my dream
that's my dream you would you would this
will happen
this will happen i want to manifest it
that's why i hope so because i've never
heard you say that before
and the fact that you said that's my i
could i believed it i was i was in the
room when you gave her the
deeds yeah i mean i was in the room
i know yeah [ __ ] cry bruh i'm sorry
cry cry you've always got to spin it
you've always got to spin it you can't
be sentimental for once
i can't that's more therapist [ __ ] the
therapies are why do i have to make
everything a joke
that's jokes yeah i have to make
everything a joke i can't be serious
about anything
but yeah that's my dream fam to sort
mom and dad out in those two specific
ways i have very specific ways
it needs to be sorted yeah bang bang and
then just get it and then just be like
oh oh my god i'll sleep for a week after
that
that'd be fantastic bro it'd just be
like that's my life i have no
i i literally don't have any dream
though like
for the success for like my idea of
success
none of it revolves around getting
anything for myself yourself yeah i
don't give a [ __ ] about any of it it all
literally revolves around sorting that
out sorting my mouth
um and making sure that like my kids
and my wife and my kids kids and
everyone is just
yeah bang like i i want
my kids to be able to ring me and just
be like dad i need
like i will never forget the day i did
my personal training course and i was
sweating because it was three and a half
[ __ ] grand
i remember i remember thinking there's
no way i can pay that yeah but i wanted
to do this pt
thing and i ran my dad and i was like
cool can you help me out with this pt
thing yeah and he said how much is it
and i was like
it's three and a half grand but you can
pay it off monthly and you just put this
deposit down
by the end by the time i'd finished
talking he was like cool it's in your
bank i took my banknotes three and a
half grand in there
and i was just like the world is
different the world is different the
world is different from and i was just
like i need to be
the dad that can do that yeah i can't be
the dad that when my kids come to me
with their financial stress
i'm now stressed because i'm financially
stressed as it is do you know you know
what i mean of course i know exactly
what you mean i can't be that dad
i physically can't be that dad i can't
be that husband
where my wife's just like i want to go
on this holiday and
i'm just like oh [ __ ] shake we can't
afford it yeah
like get it in your [ __ ] head or the
car's broken down
and i'm like ah
you're you're gonna have to take the bus
then love because we're [ __ ]
you know i mean i can't be that dad i
refuse
fam i can't be the husband i refuse if
you man don't
send us some more patreons after this
episode if you man don't sign up after
this episode
we poured our hearts out to you if we
had to sign up after this episode to
patreon
yeah you're pagans you're pagans mothers
you're all pagans yeah man yeah
that's the dream g i hope people i hope
people who have a dream can listen and
think [ __ ] it
let's go yeah let's go because there's
certain times in your life where you
just have to
think like because i know so many people
sit on a day to day today and are just
like
this is just my lot in life do you know
what i mean there's always they've
always got that thing that they want to
do
that they're like this this is the
answer whether it's like
clothes or [ __ ] writing a book
or taking up that like like art school
that they've always wanted to do
or just like the thing that is like a
long road or getting in [ __ ] forex
[ __ ]
bitcoin whatever you want to do just
like taking the leap and just like
i know if i did this or if you asked him
you could ask anyone like what would you
love to do
everyone's got a [ __ ] answer and it's
so annoying that so many people have an
answer but no one's doing anything about
it
and it's just like i'd love someone to
listen to this today and be like
[ __ ] this bro i'm doing it i'm jumping
on i'm doing it yeah bro
i'm 20 years old i'm [ __ ] 16 years
old i'm young
even if i'm 45 years old i'm i'm doing
it bro because
three four years down the line i can i
can be where you can be
i never thought i would be yeah exactly
i never thought i would be exactly
remember when i um when he was watching
that um
that ali abdal video the other day yes
about how much pee he made yes
if you guys want a motivational video
there's a youtuber called ali abdal
um he's from the uk and he made a video
a few months ago or i think
yeah a couple months ago of how much
money he made in 2020 and i've been
following him for like a year now maybe
and he's a really good guy he makes like
he's very well spoken and some people
might find him a bit boring but he's
very eloquent well spoken
crispy content yeah crispy content yeah
yeah yeah
and he made a video of how much he
turned over a mill in 2020 2020
and he breaks it down to the penny yeah
of where audience yeah like the
resources he got it from
and he talks about his journey as to
where he got this and he talks about oh
i made this much money in 2018 i made
this much money in 2019. he's gone from
making like 30 grand in 2018 to turn
into a million in 2020 20 yeah and this
isn't a joke
it's not it's not a joke but the one
thing he says is just like bro
anyone who's interested in youtube and
this applies to anything in life it's
not just youtube or
podcasting or any it replies to
everything not just like creating
content for example
do it two to three times a week every
week
for two years two years and then come
chat to me and i promise you your life
will change
and that applies to anything you want to
do is just like dedicate two days a week
to it
every week for two years and your life
will be different hundred percent
your life will be different from just
have to be dedicated
yeah you have to be dedicated whether
you want to be a [ __ ] architect
or a doctor or like like i said like a
sound engineer or
a musician or anything like pick up that
piece of equipment or get on youtube and
learn that take that course
or something and just dedicate two days
a week every week
two years come chat to me your life's
going to be different
you're not not necessarily be rich but
your life will be difficult i've changed
forever seeing significant differences
from when you started to where you are
right now 100
and we've already seen it of course
we've because we're not at the end goal
yet yeah it's so easy about [ __ ] this is
taking ages
but we only had this studio in november
in november and it feels like we've been
in forever yeah as you know i mean it's
true we feel like i feel like we've been
in the studio forever we have more
episodes on the sofa than we do
on in the studio way more episodes on
the sofa than we do in the studio good
it feels like you've been in the studio
forever
yeah good shot but it's like you don't
know until you start
bro you don't know until you start i
don't think we'll be in the studio
a year into what we're doing bro i am
some girl commented on one of the on the
episode one the other day yeah and was
like oh this is my third time
watching it and i saw the thumbnail from
episode one i was like yeah
what the [ __ ] is that that is [ __ ] i
don't know it's not
everyone's like whoa we've come we've
come like yeah and obviously i still
keep looking
i very rarely look back i'm always like
next thing next thing next thing next
thing
but yeah when you take time on
reflection just bro
two days a week [ __ ] every week two
years and obviously not even at two
years yet
your life will be different and when we
are at two years even if i don't make
another penny
from now until our two-year mark the the
the method still applies of course
because if when we get to our two-year
mark even if we're exactly where we're
at now
yeah you look back and be like my life
is different my life is
obviously changed my life is different
now i've
i'm not gonna say use the word influence
but we've changed a lot of people's
lives but i changed people's lives my
bank account is different now it's
different
we make clothes
creative designers people want to send
us stuff like our life is completely
different
bro completely different people pay us
to say [ __ ]
now we get noticed do you know what i
mean things like that is is crazy mum
so yeah it can apply to anything we talk
to people from all
over the world all over every single day
we get messages from
everywhere every single day talking
about
look at this [ __ ] tarantula that was
in my office today that's crazy
oh did you know there's [ __ ] baboons
in kenya that are climbing all over my
yard
that's crazy i remember that yeah yeah
yeah like am i the [ __ ] for this
situation that's going on in my life and
[ __ ] now that's nuts and just like
all right guys like you might be
interested in this and like oh if you
ever come to this country
you should stay here and like and
everyone's like it's crazy
we're not even at the two years i
remember when we were when we first
first jumped on we were
begging people to send us oh fam even
before am i the [ __ ] started we're
like oh
we want to talk about this guys please
send us in some stuff to talk about this
and nothing nothing episode probably
like episode 20s 30s
yeah bro we were in it we were in it we
were in it
our dms were dry because but the one
thing i'm happy about is that we treated
it like
we treated it like we had a million
subscribers when we had two
yeah so i mean there was missing an
episode was not
an option it wasn't an option that's the
thing with consistency ma'am
you have to keep the ball rolling you
have to keep the ball rolling
so don't expect us to oh don't expect
you to
be where you want to be in two years
without putting in the graph for all
every week for two years
yeah bro you just can't miss a week yeah
yeah just go miss an app you can't miss
a day
you can't miss a lesson whatever it is
you want to do in life just dedicate two
years to it solidly
bro two days a week two years every week
bang your life's different now it's the
same everything like literally [ __ ]
going gym bruv
you're going gym you go gym three days a
week every week for two years your life
will change you're different
now you feel different you're gonna eat
probably eat differently because
everything's different
so yeah bro someone please today there's
i know
at least a hundred people that would
listen to this uh or watch this there's
at least 100 of you
that have that [ __ ] thing that you
want to do at least a thousand of you to
be fair
there's at least a thousand of you that
are there's got that [ __ ] one thing
that you want to do that you're too
scared to do it
bro today's the day get the [ __ ] up
two days a week every week for two years
now right on the calendar and just
like mondays and wednesdays for the next
two years
i i've got i'm gonna be here for another
70 [ __ ] years
do you know what i mean i might as well
start now just do two just take two
years and just see what happens and if
it doesn't
work out then [ __ ] it drop it off
promise you big man it's going to work
it's going to work out because you're
not going to drop it off something
something
there will be one million after that two
years you can say there's a there's
something that is in your life now as a
consistency
that you can directly trace back to
starting out two years ago
it may not be the exact same thing but
there is something now that's different
in your life because you started this
thing two years
ago without a shadow of a doubt yeah bro
you gotta create your own luck man
and he spoke yeah he spoke about
creating your own likes or the perfect
thing in there is about like
obviously you have to be lucky for
things to be successful but you can also
create your own luck yeah and it goes
about like
you can be a person who decides like all
right cool
i'm going to start a conversation with
10 people a day every day now
and it's just like and then you happen
to like meet the woman of your dreams
or the man of your dreams or whatever
and someone say oh you're just lucky
like yeah i am lucky but i also spoke to
[ __ ] 10 people a day every [ __ ]
day i created that luck if i didn't do
that then i never would have
met that person it's a habit it's a
force of habit bro
force yourself to get in there bro and
then uh yeah guys
um if you want message us uh these
dreams obviously we've shared
shared um those it is uh very
therapeutic to just like actually put it
in the universe it is i'm a big advocate
for speaking [ __ ] into reality you have
to
like what do you think that picture like
you said like when you said you could
see the the the the deeds there and
stuff like that one i can [ __ ] see it
there's no reason why it can't happen
yeah that can happen now because i've
said it if you just like
wash it by yeah i'm a big believer and
just like i want to like [ __ ]
pick up the phone my dms are open g just
type it like james
listen to the episode i want to do
big man go go go the floor is yours
there's no excuses now you said it you
do it you always
you always do that
yeah but i hope you guys hope you guys
took this one
very seriously this is a this is a
different kind of one of the deep ones
yes
they happen every once in a blue moon
and i love the deep ones anyway i do
yeah everyone let's uh let's wrap this
paper up man i hope you guys enjoyed
sign up to the patreon you know the
vibes